hallo schönen guten Abend willkommen zu
ZDF heute live Deutschland im Sommer
2023 wir haben regelmäßig Temperaturen
über 30 Grad und gleichzeitig kann sich
jeder fünfte dieses Jahr keinen Urlaub
halten leisten Abkühlung oder ein Hauch
von Urlaub das gibt's dann oft für die
meisten nur im Freibad aber ausgerechnet
dort wird immer wieder kommt es zu
Zwischenfällen es wird gespuckt gepöbelt
beleidigt oder auch geprügelt so viel
vergangenes Jahr in Berlin Steglitz
solche Bilder Schlägereien und Freibad
Gruppen junger Männer oft mit
Migrationshintergrund auch in diesem
Sommer gibt es Vorfälle und Bilder davon
hier ein Polizeieinsatz nach Randale in
Berliner Prinzenbad
und das hier soll eine Schlägerei in
Saarlouis im Saarland zeigen
Berliner Bademeister kritisieren in
einem Brand Brief vergangene Woche
täglich werde die Badeordnung
vorsätzlich missachtet verbale Attacken
das Spucken oder pöbeln sei an der
Tagesordnung die Folge des kolumbia-bad
in Berlin-Neukölln wurde zuletzt für
eine Woche geschlossen
weil sich so viele Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter krankgemeldet hatten seit
heute ist das columbiabad wieder
geöffnet und wir wollen wissen wie es
dort ist ob sich was geändert hat und
vor allem was tun gegen Gewalt im
Freibad ihr könnt gerne mitreden
schreibt eure Kommentare oder eure
Fragen einfach in die Chats oder schickt
uns eine Mail wir sprechen später mit
Kevin Gurka vom Projekt Respekt Lotsen
in Stuttgart und mit der
Integrationsbeauftragten von
Berlin-Neukölln balte und jetzt gehen
wir dorthin wo es den Ärger gab zum
columbiabad in Berlin dort steht meine
ZDF heute live Kollegin Victoria
Reichelt hallo Viktoria
hallo Jessica
Victoria du kennst das kolumbia Bad ganz
gut weil du selber auch gerne hingehst
schon seit langem heute hat es Freibad
ich habe gesagt nach einer Woche wieder
geöffnet wie war's
ja es hat nach einer Woche wieder
geöffnet und wie du wie Ihr vielleicht
seht es hat auch schon wieder zu denn es
hat heute ein bisschen früher
geschlossen an sich war das eigentlich
ein ruhiger Tag hier im Columbia Bad wir
stehen hier natürlich mit Kamera und da
kamst du so ein kleinen Zwischenfall wir
haben hier noch verschiedene Stimmen
eingesammelt und da haben sich dann zwei
Jugendliche von gestört gefühlt und die
haben noch unserem Kameramann einmal mit
so einer Cap auf dem Hinterkopf gegeben
das war natürlich eine nicht so schöne
Situation aber ich muss sagen abseits
davon war es eigentlich ein recht
ruhiger Tag im kolumbia Bad es ist
natürlich nicht cool auf der anderen
Seite muss man sagen ein paar wenige von
vielen vielleicht insgesamt deinen Fazit
du hast mit den Leuten gesprochen was
genau badeschluss war heute um 17 Uhr
ich bin von vorher mal reingegangen wie
so oft ich gehe bestimmt einmal die
Woche ins columbiabad und habe mich da
einfach mal mit den Leuten unterhalten
und ehrlich gesagt sind die meisten
Leute im columbia-bad heute eher so ein
bisschen verwirrt von der pressepräsenz
die ihr heute herrscht ich war wohl
nicht die erste Reporterin die sie
angesprochen hat und nach ihrem Erlebnis
gefragt hat und der Tenor den ich da so
rausgehört habe ist das ja es gibt diese
Problematik und die gibt es auch schon
seit einigen Jahren viele sind aber ein
bisschen von der Bericht Erstattung
verwundert und fragen sich auch warum
man immer wieder dieselben Videos sieht
ja teilweise schon ein Jahr eineinhalb
Jahre alt sind was eigentlich alles
sagen es gibt diese Problematik oft
bekommt man davon aber als nicht
Beteiligter im kolumbia aber gar nichts
mit und es ist wirklich eine ganz ganz
kleine Gruppe von Menschen die auch
schon bekannt ist den Mitarbeiten in den
Besuchern die hier seit vielen Jahren
hingehen die immer wieder Stress machen
und das nervt natürlich das ist blöd das
ist aber tatsächlich nur ein ganz ganz
kleiner Prozentsatz an Menschen und
viele sind auch überrascht darüber wie
jetzt ganz Deutschland auf das
kolumbia-bad als Hotspot guckt das ist
ein Bad in Neukölln wie gesagt ich gehe
hier selber oft hin und dieses
badspiegelt eigentlich wieder was wir in
ganz Neukölln kennen da kommen ganz ganz
verschiedene Menschen aus verschiedenen
Milieus zusammen und verbringen hier den
Sommer und viele sind so ein bisschen
enttäuscht darüber dass diese
Berichterstattung und die Aufmerksamkeit
jetzt so krass auf dem columbiabad liegt
weil dieses Problem gibt es schon seit
vielen Jahren und viele sagen sie
bekommen das selten oder gar nicht mit
und ich habe auch noch mal ein paar
Stimmen eingesammelt hier fuhren am
Ausgang als beim badeschluss war ähm die
kommen jetzt
ich gehe jetzt schon seit Jahren ins
kolumbierbad und ich war ehrlich gesagt
noch einige Male da als das geräumt
wurde und man bekommt das eigentlich gar
nicht mit wenn man da hinten legt und im
Becken was passiert also mich schreckt
es nicht ab das ist nicht alles so
schlimm wie es erzählt wird meines
Erachtens was nichts damit zu tun hat
das natürlich trotzdem das Personal
sicherlich unterbesetzt ist und
überfordert ist auch zum Teil und das
hat aber nicht ausschließlich was mit
irgendwelchen Jugendlichen zu tun die
hier schwimmen gehen ich habe einmal
eine Schlägerei mitbekommen letztes Jahr
und ähm ja wir müssen alle wir mussten
alle raus und es ist schade dass dann
wegen ein paar Leuten der das ganze Bad
für alle geschlossen wird ist nicht fair
ne und auch nicht für die Mitarbeiter
das kann ich auch ganz gut verstehen
also dass man den Ausweis her zeigen
muss wenn man reingeht finde ich
persönlich natürlich nicht toll aber
wenn die Leitung ist nicht anders unter
Kontrolle kriegt irgendwie die Situation
hier zu beherrschen dann habe ich dafür
noch Verständnis
die große mediale Aufmerksamkeit hat
natürlich auch damit zu tun dass sie
Bademeisterin und Bademeister in diesem
Brand Brief Alarm geschlagen haben und
dass das kolumbia war jetzt eine Woche
geschlossen war und jetzt hat es eben
wieder auf und wie wollen die Behörden
jetzt sicherstellen dass es künftig
ruhig bleiben soll
ja wir haben es gerade schon in den
schönen gehört die Bäder versuchen das
ganze jetzt über Ausweiskontrollen zu
regeln und wie die Behörden reagieren
das erklärt nicht ich sondern dazu habe
ich mir einen gastforce Columbia
erwartet geladen das ist Stefan W ist
der Chef der landesschef in Berlin von
der Gewerkschaft der Polizei hallo Herr
schön dass Sie da sind guten Abend Frau
Reichelt
wir haben es gehört es gibt immer wieder
Aufruhr es gibt Stress im kolumbia-bad
in der Köln aber auch in anderen Bädern
in Berlin können Sie uns
charakterisieren wer sind die die da
Gewalt ausüben für Unruhe sagen kann man
die auf eine Art charakterisieren na wir
reden schon seit Jahren als GDP in
Berlin darüber dass wir kleinere Gruppen
haben meist männlich die in den
einzelnen Bädern ja für Stress sorgen
für Unmut auch für Aggressionen das ist
jetzt wie das Thema der GdP seit letztem
Jahr mittlerweile schon
ja und dieser Br
and bringen ja Mitarbeiter und mit
Arbeiter nie gehört Polizeipräsenz zu
Unterstützung das wird jetzt gelöst über
mobile wachen die in den Bädern sind
kann die Polizei sowas überhaupt
durchgehend leisten also mobile Waffen
haben wir am täglichen Geschäft das
können wir leisten mobile machen aber
mehr geht halt wirklich nicht wir
fordern seit ich glaube seit zwei Jahren
seit drei Jahren sogar Konzepte gerade
dass die Mitarbeitenden in den Bädern
wissen wir haben sich zu verhalten wie
können wir als Polizei mit ihnen Kontakt
treten dass wir vernünftig und sauber
arbeiten wenn Straftaten passieren und
auch kurz bevor sie passieren
jetzt hat er neue CDU-Generalsekretär
Carsten Linnemann ja gefordert dass
Menschen die hierfür Aufbruch sorgen die
zu Tätern werden eigentlich am selben
Abend noch vorgeladen werden und dass da
Rechtsprechung also Urteile am selben
Tag passieren sollen jetzt hat SPD
Innenpolitiker Sebastian vieler im ZDF
gesagt dass wäre kein guter Vorschlag
das wäre eigentlich nicht möglich was
ist denn aktuell möglich weil es gibt ja
diese ladungs diesen ladungsprozess von
24 Stunden der da eigentlich erfolgen
sollte oder naja diese schnellprozesse
von denen geredet wurde die sind
natürlich echt schwierig in der
Umsetzung wir reden ja aber komplexe
Tatbestände wo wir Zeugen vernehmen
müssen wo wir also ein bisschen mehr
machen müssen als nur du und abends geht
zum Richter also die Idee dahinter kann
ich verstehen dass man den Rechtsstaat
stark machen möchte nach außen zeigen
möchte hier bis hier und nicht weiter
aber wir wollen im Rechtsstand natürlich
die Gewaltenteilung nicht übergehen und
wir müssen natürlich die Polizei
arbeiten lassen und auch die Gerichte
das hier Dinge verkürzen könnten bei
noch mehr Personal oder bessere
Ausstattung ja das wäre eine Option aber
der Rechtsstaat muss funktionieren und
kann nicht mit populistischen Maßnahmen
nach vorne getrieben werden
ja so viel dazu was die Behörden jetzt
tun wollen zu einem Problem was auf
jeden Fall schon länger bekannt ist
Liebe Victoria wir haben noch eine Frage
aus dem Chat den du vielleicht die du
vielleicht an Herrn W weitergeben kannst
an no Saint möchte auf Youtube wissen
kann man den nachweislichen Tätern kein
Hausverbot erteilen
ich habe hier noch eine Frage aus dem
Chat für Sie hier gefragt jemand ob man
den
hausfriedensstörern nicht einfach ein
Hausverbot erteilen kann ja das
Hausverbot kann man erteilen die sind
Hausrecht Inhaber und da kommt in Berlin
natürlich der Tatbestand entgegen dass
wir den Menschen namentlich mittlerweile
erfassen also die Bäderbetriebe können
natürlich den Namen speichern und auch
ein Hausverbot vor Ort aussprechen und
dann ist das erstmal gültig und kommt
derjenige dem Haus verboten nicht nach
dann kommt die Polizei nicht spielen
dann die beiden Haus Friedensbruch auf
eine Straftat für die derjenige auch
belangt wird im Nachhinein
ja und diesen um dieses Hausverbot
besser durchzusetzen da werden wir jetzt
auch Personalausweise Reisepässe
kontrolliert ich bin ja vorhin auch rein
und meinen Ausweis hat man auch
kontrolliert also jede Person die ihr
heute reingegangen ist er muss den
Ausweis vorzeigen auch keine leichte
Aufgabe für die Beschäftigten der auch
so ein bisschen unter Personalmangel
leiden wieder gehört haben Liebe
Viktoria ich danke Dir ganz herzlich
auch für dein Interview und wünsche euch
noch einen schönen Abend in Berlin
danke und wir bleiben in Berlin wir
gehen direkt weiter zur
Neuköllner Integrationsbeauftragten
günär balte guten Abend guten Abend Frau
sie haben in der Zeit mal beschrieben
wie sie ihre Kindheit im columbia-bad
verbracht haben und dass diese
Schwimmbad für Sie und für viele andere
ganz ganz wichtiger ja vielleicht sogar
ein Sehnsuchtsort und eine wichtige
Begegnungsstätte war was ist seitdem
schief gelaufen
also wir hatten auch früher schon
Konflikte in dem Schwimmbad es gab auch
immer mal eine Prügelei so ist es nicht
das war jetzt nicht immer nur ein Ort
des absoluten Friedens weil auch damals
schon sind da Welten aufeinander
getroffen ich glaube das hat sich ja
wirklich verstärkt auch in den letzten
Jahren und das hat ganz verschiedene
Ursachen was ich so bedauerlich finde
ist wenn ich jetzt heute höre ich war
heute auch in kolumbia Bad und habe mich
da mit dem Personal und mit den Gästen
unterhalten ich gehe da auch öfter hin
also es ist eins der beliebtesten und
schönsten Bilder die wir haben
tatsächlich in Berlin und ich finde
schade zu hören dass wir um 17:30 Uhr
schließen müssen weil das ist das
eigentliche Problem für mich also für
mich ist der Umstand das ist der
Konflikte gibt das ist nichts Neues ist
tatsächlich ja die haben sich verändert
die haben sich verlagert die haben sich
wahrscheinlich auch verstärkt in Teilen
ganz klar aber wichtig ist es vor allem
zu gucken was können wir den Menschen
anbieten damit Sie weiterhin Sorgen los
schwimmen gehen können und
damit wir diese Gewalt eindämmen und
verhindern und da müssen wir ganz viele
Ideen zusammenbringen also das ist ja
jetzt schon mal gut heute war es ein
wunderbar friedlicher Tag als ich da war
und wenn man die Badegäste fragt dann
ist das tatsächlich so wie das ihre
Kollegin gerade geschildert hat die sind
total überrascht darüber dass das jetzt
so ein riesen Fokus ist auf ihrem
lieblingsbad da gehen die alle trotzdem
regelmäßig hin trotz der Prügeleien und
Rangeleien was wir auf jeden Fall
verhindern müssen ist dass diese Gewalt
weiterhin so auch so Eklat dann eklatant
da stattfinden kann und das ist einfach
nicht schön für sehr viele Kinder und
Jugendliche die dann eben doch
vielleicht im Mitleidenschaft gezogen
werden obwohl sie gar nicht Teil des
Ganzen sein wollen ja also die
allermeisten
Badegäste sind sehr vernünftige Menschen
die einfach auch gar keine Lust auf
diese Gewaltexzesse haben die dort ab
und anstatt finden und um was zu ändern
muss man die Ursachen verstehen und auch
darüber sprechen woher kommt diese Lust
auf Randale Krawall Frauen belästigen
schwule beleidigen der Psychologe hat
dazu eine klare Meinung die hören wir
uns kurz an die Gewalt hat viel mehr mit
patriarchische Strukturen zu tun und mit
eine neue Dimension von Jugendkultur die
toxischer Männlichkeit und Gewalt
verherrlicht und sogar anerkannt und das
muss in aller Deutlichkeit benannt
werden
würden sie das so unterschreiben
toxische Männlichkeit ist das eines der
Grundprobleme ich habe also toxische
Männlichkeit ist nicht so mein begriff
was ich auf jeden Fall auch sehe ist
dass es auf jeden Fall ein
Rollenverständnis ist was sehr schwierig
ist für eine bestimmte Gruppe ganz klar
und das ist natürlich ein
Männlichkeitsbild wo man eben Macht
demonstriert durch eine gewaltdominanz
die man dann da auslebt das ist eine
bestimmte Gruppe die das macht und die
Gruppe die darunter leidet ist wiederum
auch eine die wahrgenommen wird als der
migrantische mann ne also ich kenne
arabische türkische kurdische albanische
Väter oder Brüder die da einfach auch
schwimmen gehen auch mit ihren Töchtern
und ihren Schwestern oder Freundinnen
oder Frauen und die haben alle überhaupt
keine Lust auf diese Art von Gewalt die
da stattfindet und deswegen muss man das
immer sehr klar auch wirklich
unterscheiden und trennen und gucken es
gibt auf jeden Fall diese Gruppen die
wurden auch benannt das waren jetzt die
Gruppen dieser migrantischen Jungs die
auffallen und was das Badepersonal ganz
klar auch herausstellt ist in der Regel
weiß man auch wer das ist man kennt dann
schon die einzelnen Leute oder die
einzelnen Gruppen und das ist für mich
ein bisschen auch so
hoffnungsstiftend weil genau daran kann
man ja ansetzen ja also das ist ja genau
das Problem dass man dem Personal nicht
die Möglichkeiten gibt und auch nicht
die Ausstattung gibt auch personell
nicht die Ausstattung gibt dem gerecht
zu werden das ist eigentlich jetzt das
worum es wirklich geht ne dass man das
in Zukunft noch besser macht dass man
präventiv noch besser arbeitet dass man
mittlerweile auch vorbereitet ist auf
das was passieren kann bei 30 Grad an
einem Sonntag wenn das Bad irgendwie
9000 Gäste ja also 9000 Gäste beherbergt
da muss man sich Gedanken darüber machen
dann muss man glaube ich ganz
pragmatisch rangehen natürlich wird das
jetzt auch von allen Seiten
ausgeschlachtet also ganz klar
Sommerloch und dann eben diese Debatte
ah da sind die bösen Migranten und jetzt
müssen wir wir guten wir müssen unsere
Ausweise vorzeigen da finden ja gerade
ganz viele
Diskussion statt im Hintergrund und in
den sozialen Medien aber worum es
eigentlich geht ist dieses Schwimmbad
hat schon immer eine besondere soziale
und kulturelle Mischung gehabt und das
ist gut so dabei gegen den Menschen
einander die einander manchmal gar nicht
begegnen ja da haben wir die
halbnacktbadenden mit den komplett
verschleiert Badenden und in der Regel
läuft das immer sehr sehr gut bis auf
diese Momente wo es komplett eskaliert
und die müssen wir einfach viel besser
in den Griff bekommen
dazu schreibt Alexander Hanel sie hatten
das eben auch schon angesprochen warum
sollen jetzt alle Gäste oder die Polizei
für das Fehlverhalten einzelner
herhalten in diesem Bädern sollen
Sicherheitsdienste aufpassen und das
Hausrecht eben verweigert werden das
Problem ist nicht neu
Hausverbote werden ständig erteilt wo
warum werden die nicht umgesetzt ist das
nicht möglich aus Personalgründen
absolut also sie müssen sich ja
vorstellen ich habe das heute mal ein
bisschen beobachtet die Leute zeigen
alle brav ihren Ausweis
wenn es dann zu einem Konflikt kommt
innerhalb des Bads musste ja auch
schnell gemeldet werden das muss auch
schnell an der richtigen Adresse landen
das ist wie das gerade der Kollege von
der Polizei gesagt hat dass Badepersonal
muss auch so geschult sein und so
aufgestellt sein dass sie sofort wissen
dass sie auch schon im Vorfeld ja also
heute hat mir jemand gesagt wenn wir die
Rutsche zu machen haben wir mindestens
über 50% weniger Probleme weil die
entstehen oft durch eine Rangelei z.B an
der Rutsche man weiß sehr viel im
Vorfeld und wenn man da äh ein bisschen
präventiv rangeht auch noch mal und das
Personal in jeder Hinsicht besser
ausstattet dann kann man sowas auch viel
besser verhindern ja also das ist das
kann man ähnlich vergleichen wie in der
Jugend Sozialarbeit zum Beispiel da
kennt man dann schon gewisse Gruppen und
gewisse Leute und ist dann gewappnet und
das ist Aufgabe einer Gesellschaft mit
so einem Problem umzugehen das ist auch
Aufgabe der Polizei und Aufgabe der
Politik und im besten Fall ohne das
auszuschlachten für eine Polarisierung
in der das sowieso schon befinden und
die E- stattfindet und das Columbia aber
zeigt wirklich eigentlich jeden Tag dass
man sehr gut miteinander umgehen kann
trotz vieler Unterschiede und auch
friedlich miteinander sein kann weil
glücklicherweise ist das die meiste Zeit
des Sommers nicht so wie in diesen
YouTube-Videos oder Twitter Videos die
wir vorhin gesehen haben aber es gibt
diese Vorfälle und sie sind zu viel und
sie dürfen auch weiterhin nicht in der
Form stattfinden ganz klar
dazu schreibt nobel auf Youtube es sind
grundsätzlich erstmal größtenteils junge
Leute ja viele mit Migrationshintergrund
aber auch ein wesentlicher Anteil
anderes es ist eher so dass die Jugend
irgendwie komplett ausrastet gefühlt ist
das ein Ansatz um zu verstehen was da
passiert das ist eine das ist auf jeden
Fall das sind junge Männer und
Jugendliche ja männliche Jugendliche und
das ist ich würde es nicht als
Jugendkultur bezeichnen ich würde es
eher als ein das ist etwas was eine
bestimmte Gruppe für sich kultiviert hat
da spielt Sozialisation eine Rolle da
spielt Rollenverständnis eine Rolle das
spielt tatsächlich auch was ist das für
eine Kinderstube wissen die Eltern
überhaupt was ihre Söhne da machen oder
oder wissen Sie gar nichts davon da
spielen sehr viele Dinge eine Rolle also
um jetzt mal so also diese Täter Profile
sich klar zu machen die sind auch
wirklich sehr vielfältig tatsächlich ja
das sind Jugendliche die sind in fünf
der Generationen hier das ist auch
völlig überflüssig zu sagen das sind
keine deutschen oder so ja und das ist
aber keine Jugendkultur sondern das ist
eine eine bestimmte Gruppe von Leuten
die so auffällt das muss man so sagen
und sie sind eine Minderheit
glücklicherweise trotzdem schaffen sie
es aber immer wieder durch ihr
brachialis Auftreten für Verunsicherung
zu sorgen in dem Schwimmbad auch dafür
zu sorgen dass auch Familien sagen ich
habe da keine Lust am Nachmittag
hinzugehen wenn ich da so Bilder sehe
übers Internet und dennoch stelle ich
aber fest die Neuköllner an sich und die
Besucher dieses Schwimmbad die auch von
allen Teilen Berlins dahin kommen sind
sehr pragmatisch weil sie einfach auch
wissen die meisten Zeit des Sommers ist
es dort sehr sehr friedlich und sehr
sehr angenehm das muss man immer wieder
betonen also das ist halt wenn man diese
Bilder sieht jetzt erstmal absurd wenn
man denkt das ist total schlimm was da
passiert betroffen sind in der Regel
aber wirklich die Leute vom Badepersonal
ja und die muss man da viel Männer
unterstützen deswegen auch diesen
Brandbrief sehr ernst nehmen ja die sind
auch sehr vielfältig aufgestellt das
sind türkischstämmige arabischstämmige
Bademeister da
griechisches Sicherheitspersonal also
das ist völlig durchmischt das heißt
betroffen sind wirklich auch die
Menschen mit dieser besagten
Migrationsgeschichte in erster Linie und
wenn man dann auf der Liegewiese ist hat
man da weniger mit zu tun wenn man aber
Jugendlicher ist und man möchte
schwimmen und sich nicht kloppen dann
kann es durchaus passieren dass man da
in so einem Burg landet und das müssen
wir absolut verhindern wir müssen
gewährleisten dass unsere Kinder und
Jugendlichen und Familien und alle die
sich nicht leisten können sich ein Pool
im Garten zu bauen oder auch so gerne
ins Schwimmbad gehen das muss gewaltfrei
laufen der tragen wir die volle
Verantwortung alle
und jetzt hat ja der neue
CDU-Generalsekretär Linnemann gefordert
dass die Täter noch am selben Tag
verurteilt werden sollen und notfalls
auch am Wochenende da gab es schon
wieder entsprechenden Reaktionen das ist
völlig unrealistisch ist und auch
populistisch sei wie stehen Sie zu dem
Vorschlag bringt es was
also ich bin keine Juristin ich kann nur
eins sagen wir haben in Neukölln also
das Neukölln ist für das Neuköllner
Modell bekannt da geht es aber
tatsächlich darum dass wirklich
Intensivtäter schnell abgeurteilt werden
sollen und je nach Straftatbestand sind
das ja sowieso Dinge die stattfinden
tatsächlich ja also das ist ja nichts
irgendwie was uns in Neukölln fremd ist
wir haben immer wieder mit extrem
Gewaltvorfällen in Neukölln zu tun
gehabt mit äh Jugendgewalt die wir
versuchen mit allen Möglichkeiten
einzudämmen präventiv zu bekämpfen aber
wie gesagt auch mit diesem Neuköllner
Modell und ähm ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass da auch die Kollegen von der
Polizei wenn sie denn rechtzeitig da
sind und vor Ort sind und ein ja auch
wirklich zu Gesicht bekommen da auch
absolut richtig handeln und da auch alle
Maßnahmen treffen also da habe ich gar
keinen Zweifel dran ich glaube nicht
dass wir da schlecht aufgestellt sind
ich finde auch gut dass jetzt eben durch
die
personalausweiskontrollen auch ein
gewisses Gefühl der Sicherheit
vermittelt wird auch all jenen die sich
da unsicher fühlen tatsächlich und vor
allem für das Badepersonal und auch die
Idee das jetzt im Außenbereich Kameras
angebracht werden sollen das hat zum
Beispiel auch in verschiedenen Milieus
wo man auch auffällig viel
Gewaltvorfälle in der öffentlichen im
öffentlichen Raum hatte dazu geführt
dass zumindest in diesem Bereichen es
ruhiger wurde ja oder nehmen wir mal das
Beispiel mit dem Alexanderplatz man weiß
dass da auch verhäuft gehäuft Gewalt
vorkommt und dann geht man damit um ja
also jetzt und und das machen wir auch
bei uns im Sommerbad kolumbia das
einfach richtig aber
das ist jetzt eine politische Debatte
die von allen Seiten für sich
instrumentalisiert wird das sind wir
auch gewohnt in Neukölln das ist auch
nichts Neues für uns ist es total
wichtig dass ich die badesituation für
die Kinder und Jugendlichen und Familien
für alle die da gerne hinkommen
verbessert
trotzdem noch mal die Nachfrage muss die
Polizei und dann eben auch die Justiz
vielleicht schneller und härter gegen
solche Krawallmacher Vorgehen ich meine
das eine ist das Freibad das andere ist
die Silvesternacht es gibt ja ganz
offensichtlich ein Problem ja klar es
gibt Probleme und
schneller und härter ist immer schnell
zur Hand weil es klingt halt gut und
richtig ja
ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher ob sie
nicht schnell genug und hart genug
durchgreifen tatsächlich also weil
letztendlich das was ich oft erlebe ist
dass die Polizei in Neukölln in solchen
Situationen oft sehr schnell durchgreift
und auch hart durchgreift tatsächlich
und ähm deswegen würde ich das gar nicht
in Frage stellen dass das nicht sowieso
schon so stattfindet also ich denke dass
da jeder
seinen Job so gut wie möglich macht und
will das gar nicht in Frage stellen und
wie gesagt
wenn es einen Straftäter gibt der im
Schwimmbad erwischt wird bei einer
schweren Straftat und es wird für nötig
befunden dass sehr schnell ab zu
urteilen dann wird das wahrscheinlich
auch stattfinden aber wie gesagt also
das ist auch gar nicht mein
Arbeitsbereich ich werde da jetzt auch
nicht die Juristin spielen und der hat
da ja auch nicht auf einem politischen
Diskurs aufspringen der uns so
eigentlich nicht weiterbringt weil
schneller und härter ist immer sofort zu
Hand wenn man irgendwie ein Gewalt Video
im Internet sieht und es kommt aus
Neukölln wenn die Polizei eingreift oder
dann eben die Staatsanwaltschaft dann
ist das ja auch erst die Reaktion nach
der Tat ähm was muss aus ihrer Sicht
passieren vielleicht zum Schluss um eben
präventiv zu agieren damit es eben gar
nicht erst zu solchen Situationen kommt
also wenn man sich in dem Schwimmbad
bewegt oder in den Schwimmbädern das ist
ja nicht nur im kolumbia war so wir
haben ja verschiedene Bilder in Berlin
wo es auch Vorfälle gab dann stellt man
wenn man wirklich mit offenen Ohren und
Augen dadurch geht und sich mit dem
Personal unterhält
stellt man sehr schnell fest wie man so
brenzlige Situationen schon im Vorfeld
eruieren kann wie man schon erkennen
kann wenn sich was anbahnt ja ich sage
jetzt mal zum Beispiel der Stau an der
Rutsche zum Beispiel oder man sieht
größere Gruppen von Jugendlichen und das
wird schon ein bisschen seltsam da da
werden gewisse Dinge schon ausgehandelt
wo man merkt das ist nichts Gutes das
heißt Prävention ist da alles und gut
ausgebildetes Personal ist da alles und
das müssen wir auch gewährleisten als
Gesellschaft für so einen Ort der auch
Konflikt beladen sein kann und da kann
man viel machen ich habe heute z.B ganz
schlecht ne ich habe irgendwie
beobachtet wie äh das Personal am
Eingang auch wirklich die Jungs
angesprochen hat sie angeguckt hat
gesagt hat ey pass mal auf heute machen
wir die Rutsche auf aber du darfst dir
keinen Stress machen und dann fühlen sie
sich ein bisschen ertappt ein bisschen
angesprochen also da ist eine Verbindung
da und man kann es dann sehr schnell
auch beobachten wenn man wirklich das
Ziel hat dafür zu sorgen dass der Ruhe
ist dann schickt man da die richtigen
Leute in das Bad und dann funktioniert
das auch ganz klar ja aber das kostet
natürlich Personal und das muss man auch
gewährleisten und dann kann man auch
einen ganzen Sommer lang durchaus ein
Schwimmbad haben wo es keine Vorfälle
gibt da bin ich mir sicher wir könnten
sowas hinbekommen wenn wir das wollten
sie sagen direkte Ansprache ist ganz
wichtig darüber wollen wir auch gleich
mit unserem nächsten gesprächskasten
noch sprechen ich danke Ihnen ganz ganz
herzlich für Ihre Zeit und das Gespräch
sehr gerne vielen Dank auch Ihnen
ja wie gesagt das Problem ist nicht neu
und das gibt seit Jahren und eben auch
in anderen Städten und deshalb gibt es
auch einige Projekte die versuchen mit
den Jugendlichen in Kontakt zu kommen
die respektlosen sind ehrenamtliche
junge Helferinnen und Helfer im Alter
zwischen 16 und 30 Jahren seit 2020 sind
sie eben nicht nur in Freibädern sondern
im ganzen Stadtgebiet von Stuttgart
unterwegs ihre Aufgabe mit jungen
Menschen meistens mit
Migrationshintergrund sprechen oder ihre
Probleme reden Respekt zeigen aber auch
einfordern und das Ziel von dem
vornherein Stress zu vermeiden zum
Denken anregen und Respekt vermitteln
und Kevin Gurka ist der Koordinator mit
ihm wollen wir jetzt noch sprechen guten
Abend
guten Abend
wie ist die Idee entstanden respektlosen
durch Stuttgart zu schicken
die Idee ging tatsächlich auch auf einen
Vorfall in einem Freibad zurück nämlich
im Stuttgarter Inselbad als ein
13-Jähriger sehr rücksichtslos Ball
gespielt hat die Badegäste gestört hat
der Bademeister hat den Amt und es sind
50 Personen haben sich im Bademeister
entgegengestellt also musste die Polizei
einrücken
wir haben uns daraufhin die Frage
gestellt in der Landeshauptstadt
Stuttgart was können wir tun wir haben
die Abteilung Integrationspolitik und
die kommunale Kriminalprävention haben
gesagt wir dürfen nicht über Jugendliche
reden sondern wir müssen mit ihnen
sprechen auf Augenhöhe wir haben
geschaut was gibt es denn in Deutschland
welche Projekte gibt es bereits wir
haben cool am Pool in Berlin uns
angeschaut wir haben Akim in München
angeschaut und dann haben wir das
Projekt gegründet zusammen mit dem
gemeinschaftserlebnissport der
Stuttgarter jugendhausgesellschaft und
im Förderverein sicheres und sauber
Stuttgart und wir sind seit 2020 august
in der ganzen Stadt unterwegs und reden
mit Jugendlichen mit jungen Menschen
respektvollen auf Augenhöhe
Respekt bedeutet ja viel
Anerkennung
Rücksichtnahme Akzeptanz und wie sie das
hinbekommen dass Jugendlichen die sehr
ansprechen eben mehr Respekt gegenüber
anderen zeigen das haben wir Ihre
respektlosen gefragt
also gerade jüngeren Mädchen so zwischen
16 und 18 bekommen wir sehr oft
Rückmeldungen dass sie sich eben unwohl
fühlen weil sie oft mitbekommen dass es
eben Ausschreitungen gab das
Belästigungen gab es gibt eigentlich
durchgehend positives Feedback es sind
Leute sind sehr offen gerade wenn man
als Mädchen auf andere Mädchen zugeht
sind diese offen heute hatten wir ein
Gespräch geführt ja wenn sie erst in
Deutsch gefragt hey habt ihr Zeit wollt
ihr mit uns reden nein nein wir wollen
nicht reden einfach weitergehen weil
dann fangen wir einfach zu fragen hey
hättet ihr arabisch können wir auch
Arabisch reden fangen wir einfach in den
Gesprächen Arabisch zu führen und sie
waren ganz offen
und du kannst schon was darunter
vorstellen und wir fokussieren uns auch
darauf im Gespräch immer wieder darauf
hinzuweisen
und das machen sie Abend
also der Ansatz ist eben vor allem auch
auf Augenhöhe miteinander zu sprechen
wie ist das denn mit der Erfolgsrate ist
natürlich schwer messbar bei so einem
Projekt aber wie wie ist so ihr zwischen
Fazit nach drei Jahren
in der Tat ist es sehr schwierig zu
messen was wir erleben ist wir kriegen
sehr gutes Feedback in den Einsätzen die
Menschen freuen sich dass jemand sie
anspricht gerade zu Corona haben wir
festgestellt die Menschen kannten das
nicht dass jemand respektvoll auf sie
zugeht und fragt hast Du kurz Zeit wie
geht es Dir magst du mir sagen was
brauchst du so was haben die Menschen
nicht gekannt wir haben tatsächlich wir
bauen noch eine Brücke zwischen Politik
und Zivilgesellschaft und Verwaltung wir
sind mit bezirksbetten unterwegs wir
haben Jugendliche eingeladen unsere
Bürgermeisterin hat mit ihnen gesprochen
in einem geschützten Raum hat sie
gefragt wie geht's euch was braucht ihr
dann einfach auf dieses Gefühl für junge
Menschen gehört zu werden was sagen zu
dürfen das merken wir das kommt bei
diesen jungen Menschen sehr sehr gut an
und sie sind natürlich sehr vielfältig
also wir können nicht von einer Jugend
sprechen sondern wir müssen im Prinzip
von Jugend denn sprechen es ist in den
Beitrag gerade schon rausgekommen wir
haben Unterschied Personen in unserem
Team unsere Team ist mehrsprachig sehr
breit aufgestellt wir haben junge
Studierende wir haben Schülerinnen und
Schüler wir haben auch geflüchtete im
Team die Meeres Sprachen sprechen
natürlich ist die Ansprache in dem
Freibad von jungen Frauen zu jungen
Frauen eine andere wir sprechen auch mit
jungen arabischen Männern wir haben
Menschen im Team die sprechen mongolisch
russisch polnisch deutsch englisch sie
lässt sich fortsetzen und wir verstehen
die Lebenswelt dieser Jugendlichen und
das ist was das kennen sie nicht dass
jemand auf sie zugehört und das eine
Stadt ihnen zuhört und diese Ansatz
kommt sehr sehr gut an es gibt eine
Frage aus dem Chat an sie die bitte Ihre
Erfahrung mit uns zu teilen die Täter
beschreiben und warum sie glauben warum
junge Migranten
Randale Krawall machen
unser Auftrag ist es für Respekt zu
senselnisieren das heißt wir sind nicht
da um Täter unmittelbar davon abzuhalten
was wir aber tatsächlich schon erleben
ist dass Jugendliche Menschen wenn wir
sie fragen was sie beschäftigt wir haben
viele Krisen wir haben sehr hohe Mieten
Jugendliche leben auf sehr engem Raum
teilweise mit hohen Mieten auch
teilweise stark kontrolliert von der
Familie da gibt es dort in denen möchte
man sich probieren wir stellen sehr
stark fest das öffentliche Räume fehlen
in den Jugendlichen sein dürfen an den
Jugendlichen Platz haben wo sie
konsumieren können so dass es sich
leisten können wo sie vielleicht auch
mal Fußball spielen können wir merken
wir haben eine sehr hohe Inflation
rassismus ist sicherlich auch ein Thema
das viele Jugendliche als
Erfahrungsschatz mitbringen das geht
auch bei der Frage los wo bewerbe ich
mich mit welcher Hautfarbe welche
Religion ist meine Bewerbung erfolgreich
man ist dies nicht wir sind die in den
Ukraine Krieg wir erleben die
Energiekrise wir haben das Erdbeben in
der Türkei und in Syrien gehabt wo viele
Leute nicht gefragt haben Entschuldigung
wie geht es Dir das sind die Erfahrungen
die junge Menschen mitbringen wenn sich
das tatsächlich auch in dem Freibad
kristallisiert ist das ein Punkt in der
Innenstadt haben wir auch junge Menschen
das hängt auch teilweise in dem Wetter
das sind sehr sehr viele Faktoren die
dazu führen und damit haben sie im
Prinzip auch die Frage von
naro beantwortet auf Youtube warum es
eben vor zehn Jahren auch ohne die
Respekt Lotsen ging was ich seitdem
geändert hat die Zeiten sind eben zum
Teil auch nicht ganz leicht für junge
Menschen vielleicht zum Schluss noch die
Frage wenn Sie mit den jungen Menschen
mit den Jugendlichen ins Gespräch kommen
was hören Sie was fehlt den was brauchen
Sie um um weniger aggressiv weniger
Gewalt bereits zu sein was was muss die
Gesellschaft
den entgegenbringen
wir hören von jungen Menschen wenn wir
uns die Fragen was wünscht ihr euch sind
es oft Ort an den sie sein können sie
wünschen sich aber auch Respekt von
älteren Menschen wenn ich mit älteren
Menschen spreche ich bin ja auch
respektlose also Respekt geben Respekt
Teilen sagen ältere Menschen oft junge
Menschen haben keinen Respekt mehr junge
Menschen erzählen uns Respekt vor
Älteren gehört zu ihren kultur ist ein
sehr großes gut für sie aber sie
erfahren diesen Respekt nicht immer
junge Frauen erzählen uns über sexuelle
Übergriffe wir fragen im Freibad wir
fragen nicht aufs Volksfesten müsste man
eigentlich auch machen
alkoholismus ist auch ein Problem in der
Innenstadt bei großen Festen
was wir schaffen auf jeden Fall ist es
junge Menschen einfach zuzuhören ihre
Bedarfe aufzunehmen und dazu gehört eben
auch niederschwelliges Angebot Räume wo
sie
sich leisten können Aufenthalt zu haben
Musiker Kaffee trinken können wo sind
Wasser trinken können wo sie auch mal
was essen können wo sie auch mal
Beispielen dürfen und einfach auch diese
Respekt aus der Gesellschaft
ich danke Ihnen dass Sie uns von ihrem
Projekt erzählt haben Grüße nach
Stuttgart
gerne ganz herzlichen Dank
ja und damit machen wir dann auch
Schluss für heute ZDF heute live vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen und fürs Mitmachen
macht's gut